That cannot be stopped.
This whole debate and we'll always be
colored by what we choose to see.
In truth,
not to see if
we cannot talk seriously.
You know,
this is not 1989 anymore.
I wonder whether when they say I'll pray
for you,
he gives that wonderful reply.
I'll think for you was looking forward
to Mary Beard,
speaking out for Berlusconi and Boris
here making the case for series a.
We run the unselfish or wearing a hat.
He's,
I think this shouldn't just be a yes or
no swipe and the shit that made me
smarter so he decides.
I think we can raise the bar from that.
I don't pick it.
Just a matter of communication and a lot
of people as well and looking for it and
an old tiny our creativity,
our humanism,
I doubt very much
whether you like it or not,
the Internet is going to happen.
We're going to join us.
We should be calling an end to the war
on drugs.
What we need to read Spanish society.
Of course hip hop enhanced the society.
Democracy is not always the best form of
government.
Barack Obama is ultimately an American
Patriot Catholic Church and is a force
for good in the world.
Are you getting the message?
There is a reason
because they matter.